[Music]
you love JK rowling through the harry
potter years you knew her mystery novels
weren't just a phase
you swore curse child was better live
you defended her right to a tweaks and
character details after the fact
you looked past all the flaws of the
first fantastic beasts to see its
potential and now this this is how you
repay our loyalty I am done standing for
you Jake a fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald you love the whimsical
world of Harry Potter
a place where trying to kill a baby just
marked him as a Roe okosan one now visit
a new chapter where they just kill
babies as The Wizarding World takes a
full turn toward a dark universe for the
bleakest wettest darkest chapter yet ok
WB suck all the joy out of Harry Potter
for Aquaman it's the Sam cuz if this
series ends up with Jacob blowing up the
Ministry of Magic with a sharpie I'm
gonna be very upset all your favorite
characters from the first fantastic
beasts are back like Newt Scamander
who's gone from awkward beast lover to
awkward chick magnet perhaps you take
off your side his lizard based love
interest she has eyes just like I said
him out there don't say that master face
maker Jacob who's still making those
faces and the dreamy Queenie who
heroically hypnotizes and kidnaps her
boyfriend I'm curious when you were
gonna wake me up after we had five kids
huh well at least she didn't join forces
with wizard Hitler oh uh but don't worry
about anyone that the first movie
established as the main characters of
the series because this one spends most
of its time with characters you've never
met or cared about with multiple
flashbacks of this lady's traumatic
childhood her love triangle with mood
and his grim suit wearing brother the
mission of this grim suit-wearing
assassin and this grim suit-wearing man
who's hunting this grim suit
boy from the first one come on so movie
is this grim-faced people in suits
talking even Dumbledore's just Jude Law
looking grim in a suit can we just go
back to Ron Weasley making dumb faces at
stuff
what thanks Weasley but while everyone
else is grimly talking the evil Grendel
wall is also mostly just talking in
living rooms on roofs in alleys in
creepy auditoriums
and while overlooking mountains at a
very swanky ski lodge all to unveil his
master plan to prevent World War two a
power lust how long will it take before
they're turning their weapons on us
wait what so what you're saying is that
wizard Hitler make some good points
p-one oh boy is there a Hogwarts Express
off this franchisor so toss away your
wizard robes and literally suit up for a
fantastic beast movie that's light on
the beasts but fantastically depressing
and start hoping for a chosen one to
show up and save this franchise because
there's still three more of these logs
to go tell me my story than you can end
it know what I'm tapped out on fantasy
prequels Oh what else is on Game of
Thrones and Lord of the Rings prequels
follow me once all you would just
kidding I'm gonna watch him starring
Emperor Palpatine Sheldon Cooper hey I'm
talking in a Blacko son American Horror
Story
a high schooler is gonna be head this
lady someday fine Jude Law as Jude Law
the greater good
great great shots and attempting to
remember the names of any of these new
characters Lee Leslie lasat faces Eva
Branagh Kedavra and wriggly sweat brow
Lieutenant Dale badinage no Frenchie
Mick mystery had no one name will be
written him glory cool cool
but uh like what are their names her
dark material leave it to Johnny Depp
tended his vaping to the Wizarding World
congratulations Spencer Porsches are
glorified Volkswagens man slugs are just
snails that can't afford housing I'm the
firestarter twisted firestarter can
someone please tell me how I get him to
say something I want him to say pal
alert